Miss France
2024 attention il y a st Selma très
belle actrice il y a Nina mteer ah oui
les gars on va pas se mentir
pour onor pour l'instance on va pas se
mentir on va pas se raconter
d'histoire je donne les noms vous me
dites ok il y a
stce dans 10 % il y a Sylvie Tellier
c'est la
présidente Adriana
carambe l'ami d'un ami voilà donc oui
Nolwen le roi et l'ami d'un ami S sont
les deux là tu vois les deux compagnons
de truc sont mes amis Nina m chef
patiser il y a MOS j'aime beaucoup
etipou ouais humoriste humoriste
humoriste comédien on se dit quoi de ce
jury alle tit la vérité place au moins
il est 100% féminin c'est pas
mal la prère fois les gars j'aimerais
j'aimerais qu'on arrête s'il vous plaît
2 minutes là g s'il te plaît bon alors
le problème c'est que je ne connais
personne ou quasiment
personne honnêtement quand vous avez
prononcé les noms j'avais regardé avant
pour moi c'est un peu faible
c'est-à-dire que pour le grand public
pour TF1 quand Jean-Pierre fouc va les
présenter jeierre fou oui oui face à lui
ça va pas peser très lourd on va dire
qui sont ces gens alors attention c'est
très estimable et cetera je trouve que
pour un jury de Miss France ça manque un
peu de charisme emblématique voilà mais
pourquoi que des femmes en
fait compris côté oui alors c'est les
femmes qui vont juger les
femmesl je pense que c'est encore un
choix pour diviser les hommes et les
femmes donné c'est pas parce que on va
mettre que des femmes qui va plus avoir
de problèm c'est si on avait mis que des
hommes
hommes manger tout me pour montrer que
la cohésion peut exister en fait est en
de dire qu'on pe pe faire choses avec
les hommes parce que sinon et que les
hommes n'ont pas le droit de juger les
femmes pour un concours parce que sinon
c'est sexiste c'est ça le problème en
momentl MO je suis d'accord mais on big
à ce
momentl ce moment on va jusqu'au bout et
onance c'est la beauté intérieure et
c'est des femmes qui juge sur des
valeurs là je suis désolé vous avez vu
elles sont toutes magnifiques elles sont
elles font toutes le même la même taille
et tout ça donc on est encore sur du sur
de la beauté sont pas cap de juger le
beuté
in arr c'est une très mavaise idée
tpectur toi tu es là pour sucer arrête
un peu rien à arrête un peu pas
ne su pas je peux dire quand même qu'
elle ét présidente pend des ann
du je dis simplement que c'est légitime
qu' va apporter un super
truc j'adore Miss France
j'adorere j de le J que de
femm un gros nom quand de on on avait
des gros noms ce moment on met une
caerine de
neuveem
fa son pas pay
je alors c'est peutêtre une bonne idée
non elles sont pas payé fait le CH
pardon tu as fait le chèque toi je
plisente ça va elles sont pas
payés je l'adore je
l'adore j'ai un petit commentaire ça
manque de star mais est-ce que Sylvie
Tellier après ça n'engage que moi n'a
pas voilà n'a pas envie de d'être
l'unique star la seule
star
don une St
non mais vous parliez de Madame Marceau
Catherine denu Isabelle je pense pas que
Sylvie Tellier aurait eu envie d'avoir à
côté
d'elleis tu veux que je l'appelle
plaisir
oui vle j'appelle des g de
missance il trouve que c'est une bonne
idée
dansellefendre j'appelle
alexiaitorippelle Alexia ou
sy
alouance si alors justement je suis à
l'antenne
bébé je
t'adore dis-moi pourquoi que des meufs
sur M France chéri ah c'est une vraie
question pourquoi parce que on s dit que
avec le décès ou c'était pas mal de
mettre à l'honneur ce que moi j'ai
considéré comme une féministe et avec
Sylvie Tellier en plus à la présidence
on s'est dit ça a du sens donc tu
prouves bien qu'en plus il y avait rien
vouis pas être là tu voulais pas être là
donc on se dit il y a qu'un mec qui
mérite d'être là cette fois
donc c'est vrai dis-moi chérie en plus
tu tu prouves qu'il n'y a pas
d'embrouille entre toi et Sylvie tier ah
non aucune voilà rappes ce qu'ils
avaient dit les gens te rappelles quoi
tu te rappelles ce qu'ils avaient dit
les gens avent dit gen bruit et ben tu
le prouveré qu' avait pas embrouille ah
non non non après après on a deux forts
caractères et tu sais que je
m'exprime toujours toi je sais tu un
taureau àend
Sagittaire foudre dis-moi confir que
personne n'est payé est-ce que tu peux
confirmer que personne n'est payé dans
le jury parce que il y en a qui nous
croi pas oh non mais qu'est-ce que tu me
racontes là allez ah e bon je t'embre
alors je trouvais que c'était al je te
dis tout je trouvais que cétait une
mauvaise idée ah oui maintenant que tu
me l'as dit je trouve ça pas mal je
t'embrasse bah ouais c'est bien tu es
Dar tu es d'A j'adore tu es la beste
t'embre ch rien bébé je t'embrasse je
l'adore je l'adore elle est vraiment
Dark et elle tas vu elleelle rentre tout
de suite dedans ça veut direelle a
préparé l'interview maintenant on
l'appelle comme ça je l'adore cette meuf
j'adore cette meuf je te jureadoreprs
jeis pas d'accord avec le féminisme pour
moi c'est pas retirer les hommes tu vois
c'est c'est la grande sœur que tout le
monde aimerait avoir je te jure Alex
Alex se défausse jamais quand rép tout
alors par contre sur il sont payé du
coup hein ou les mec on va pas faire de
polémique concernant ré rép manière bien
sûr c'est toi en fait tu as toujours des
mauvaises infos pourquoi tu travailles
pas pour complément
[Applaudissements]
d'enquête a toujours les enfants à m'a à
toujours à alors je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce qu'il y a longtemps j'ai
fait partie du j pars ont pas V donner
de P to
payé personne n'a été payé je me
souviens voilà personne bah c'était une
année
creuse 72 pas les
gens oui qu'est-ce qui se passe me vous
avez mal interprété ce qu'elle a dit
personne n payé voilà et toi tu fais
gaffe non mais c'est ça le problème le
weekend tu passes tout le weekend avec
des vieux tu arrives ici tu r d'Es non
mais sans déconner tu arrives ici la la
meuf elle elle est
qu mer
toutes l'émission j'entends un B comm un
bourdon on dirait que j'ai un bourdon
non mais depuis tout à l'heure parce
qu'elle passe tout le weekend avec des
elle est commpr Mar tout l'émission
parce moi j'en ai
marre c'est
[Applaudissements]
ça un autre facteur important c'est que
c'est une très bonne audience et que
tout le monde veut y aller dans le jury
parce que sympathique ouais ouais s'il
te plaît bah la prof personne y aller
e moi je tu sais quoi aujourd'hui bravo
euh elle dit la vérité excuse-moi frère
il y en a non il y a deux trois personne
mais tu peux faire un jury beaucoup plus
fort je suis désolé frère excuse-moi
raison oui mais pourquoi tu les défends
comme ça tu as un truc avec eux rien du
tout je sais pas'exlique
ouais je sais alors je sais que c'est la
même maison mais non non moi je arrive
et ben c'est ça va oniss pas on va pas
te
virer c'est bien elle est légitime mais
non il a un truc c'est pas possible je
vous dis monel il a un truc avec les je
vais trouver ce que c'est je vais
appeler demain quelqu'un fais ga jeais
appeler tout le monde vite ton
sac on voit les limites de la culture de
certains stieelma par exemple elle était
dans 10 % elle é éta dans plusieurs film
est magnifique attends voilà elle est
magnifiqueès grand non mais non mais on
s'en fout tu vas pas n faire tout j
frère arrête de dire des conneries il y
a des il y a des gens mais arrête arrête
s'il te plaît arrête un peu c'est parce
que tu fais RFM un truc arrête un peu
frérot il y a pas des stars arrête un
peu il y a trois quatre stars oui mais
c'est pas tu vas dans la rue demande à
ma mère je te dis que ma mère elle en
connaitt tro sur qu euh de deux sur de
sur 5 Adriana c'est parce que tu sur la
chaîne animaux non ouais c'est sûr que
c'est ça ti Moro 2023 lu ouais ouais non
2024 2024ou ouais c'est ça non non non
mais tu es chelou avec Miss ouais je te
dis on trouvera tu as pris un billet un
bail comme ça toi je te dis je te
connais j'aais bien animer la soirée
moi jamais personne jamais personne ne
prendra la place de mon ami Jean-Pierre
foucco c'est le meilleur est excellent
c'est le
meilleur je te le dis voilà jamais
personne ne prendra sa place moi vivant
jamais personne ne prendra sa place dans
la place dis c'est surtout pas Bernard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Montiel
pas avec ça non mais ça vraiment et ça
pour le coup vraiment ça ne me fait pas
rire du tout ah non non mais vraiment
Jean-Pierre c'est vraiment c'est mon
c'est mon c'est ma vieou c'est il est
exceptionnel qu'est-ce que je l'aime
mais qu'il est con lui non mais sans
rigoler doit être jaloux il est jaloux
c'est son genre en tout cas à mon avis
c'est lui quiit faire sacré soiré à la à
la base après ils ont pris Jean-Pierre
foucon V non non c'est quoi l'histoire
avec Jean-Pierre non pas du tout j'adore
Jean-Pierre il s'brouill un mec
formidable c'est le plus gentil du monde
en plus alors lui voilà bien
contrairement à moi qui critique
personne est formidable mais il en pense
pas moi quand il parle quand on parle de
toi je vois s'il m'a pas écrit tiens ah
on sait jamais peut-être qui et ben
voilà c'est bien ce que je pensais
Bernard et quoi est ce que je
pensais il m'a fait un commentaire sur
toi alors il a fait quoi il a dit quoi
il aime de moins en moins ta
guule non non et ils sont payés le jury
je te le dis tu crois que on m'a dit
ouais Jean-Paul gotier alin Delon l Rena
tu crois qu'il V pour zé ballich pour la
beauté mais frère mais bien sûr qu'il
Prenn un billet tu es fou quoi c'est
normal frère dire ils t' même pas pris
pour une tête d'affiche ah non alors
nous on était plusies il onont pris pour
une
affiche de G je te jure c'est tout euh